hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
watching the trailer today for a movie
called run all night so liam neeson
action film Liam Neeson the like 60 year
old action star now I was in his fifties
I forgot how old he is exactly my
daughter she was taken I don't know much
about this film all I know is Liam
Neeson was once a intense dramatic actor
and now he is an intense action star who
elevates movies with his strong
performances but doesn't take enough of
those strong performances and sit just
really strong movies whatever let's
watch this trailer 15 years I've been in
here place looks so funny well the old
places look different a lot like Moore
never cared about you killed my son I
pulled the trigger I kill daddy yeah he
was gonna shoot Michael I'm here asking
for my son's life
he's a good kid he's got a family he
don't deserve this you know
I'm coming after your boy with
everything I got and when it's done and
it will be done and I'll let you die no
[ __ ]
and if you can't get in you is going to
go after your family
just got in tonight tell everyone to get
ready just come
right now we're the most wanted man in
this day
and now if this works they're gonna
start pulling your life apart people his
wife's family's house anyway we might
rub for our you've got to worry about
Stanko life I'm the best chance you've
got listen to your father for one night
oh nice it's like the shotgun was
spinning close up on it it looked bad
acident oh just like this small little
noise went off there's a little tiny
bullet what people tend to do when Liam
Neeson comes out with a new movie is go
Oh another Liam Neeson action movie well
it looks better than taken this film
does look better than taken I'll give it
that
I mean it still doesn't look the most
original what immediately start hooking
me about it would be the performance by
Ed Harris and Liam Neeson on the same
screen together like Ed Harris he kinda
reminds me of his role in history of
violence a little bit you know there's
definitely some differences he's the
actual boss this time around I mean the
opening of that trailer was cool when he
said that all changed an hour ago before
you killed my son I think the movie
would be neat Mike hey writers I have a
suggestion for you put that scene at the
very beginning like don't show us like
everything to happen before they if you
can just set it up with that one scene
that would be [ __ ] sweet I don't mind
cut twos and flashbacks and stuff like
that's all fine but I think it'd be
really interesting if it just was like
right in the middle of it I kind of like
the theme they got the father and son
theme they got going on like the
children suffer from the sins of their
father that errors the son is killed
because he was gonna kill Liam Neeson's
kid that is an actually interesting
story I really respect that plot point I
mean it when you got like the criminal
underworld kind of playing like that
that's really interesting I mean it
looks like it could be a good action
film but more than that if executed
properly it could be a really good
suspenseful thriller I imagine there be
some good tension-filled chemistry
between ed Harris and Liam Neeson which
is like the number one reason why I'd
probably check this film out being
advertised as an action movie as far as
like action I there's nothing no none of
the action to me was like oh I have to
watch this now cuz I look how cool the
action is it seems like it's more
focused on character and suspense drama
like if if those elements all
worth the action will need to be so
[ __ ] unique and crazy because the
action will be really felt and the
suspense will be felt in the action
because we were so invested in the
characters it looks like they're really
trying to hook us with the characters in
this you know they kind of got that
diehard five thing going on were two
badasses father and son gotta work their
way out of this situation they're in
that's right that's right
diehard five was a piece of [ __ ] but
this movie looks better than a hard five
I wish we got more this kind of trailer
I saw for like a brief moment what's
that guy's name Vincent do you know I'm
for know don't form whatever you guys
know but I think we saw him for like a
moment in the trailer and he's a great
actor like he when he's in know any
scene he tends to elevate the movie
right then and there this movie I
honestly think could be a really
suspenseful time I hope it's done well
because I like the story I like the
actors they got going on here I like
when it changed to the Danny Boy music
in the trailer I like it when trailers
do that where they take you know like a
pretty song and then they darken the
[ __ ] out of it just as a trailer I don't
know if that's gonna be like that in the
movie but in the trailer it works and I
like it it seems like it's gonna be on
this thing where it starts off with just
Ed Harris Liam Neeson ed Harris's people
and then suddenly like cops are getting
involved and then it's just getting out
of control like I I hope it escalates in
a very entertaining way man it's like
there's so much potential with this film
and it looks like it could be a great
like Hollywood script that I hope it
really does its job done well well okay
don't believe in retakes so that's gonna
stand all right guys thanks for telling
me our trailer was out if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects I'm gonna be shouting
people out now how Gonzalez hi guys I
love the channel it's so so so funny
with the videos I learn a little of
English so that's good I want to shout
out to my name is Alvaro not the name of
this Facebook and I'm from Spain have a
good day
a la bow Gonzalez you are one sexy
[ __ ]
you have hair so prickly they could
scratch the lips of a woman teeth so
beautiful it is as yellow as my you're a
pal Alvaro I don't know why your name
says pow
well I'll borrow if you're from Spain it
means you're one sexy [ __ ]
Isaac Armstrong Ryan can you shout me
out because you're a triple threat
you're funny smart and obviously great
with the ladies am i right wink wink
Isaac Armstrong I'm not gonna lie your
photos on your facebook don't make you
look like you like you're a good-looking
dude you're not a bad-looking dude at
all man like seriously congratulations
you can get who Danny one day but
where's the charm where's the love in
your photos where's the sexy side man
you just do look so serious and then you
got weird freaky photos man dude if you
want to get a lady's like the right guy
was able to score a hot lady you're
gonna need to know had a social network
yourself a little bit better
first off ladies love dick pics okay
send dick pics second ladies of [ __ ]
pics send pictures of your [ __ ] third
ladies love pictures of [ __ ] in the
toilet wash your pee don't listen to any
of that advice